[Music]
Alon mport welcome to a startup Nation
United um very difficult circumstances
but in in the next um short session
we're going to hopefully uh create um
internal inspiration and external
inspiration as to what does it mean for
uh groups and organizations to come
together under a unified Mission um in
time of conflict in time of war in time
of um heavy heavy hearts and a lot of
sadness but through United effort
creating very positive impact in an
ecosystem um it's been phenomenal to see
what our ecosystem has been creating
over these last several weeks in light
of the terrible terrible events from
October 7th and onwards and um and I'm
I'm very much looking forward to getting
inspired from the story of Maven and
their organization you're part of and
and your personal involvement there tell
me before we even talk about the you
know October 7th and the the efforts
that you've been doing shed some light
for me on on who you are what is Maven
in the outside of the context of the war
yeah so mavens is uh uh we were
originally established as store Maven
the company has existed for about uh
eight years if I'm not mistaken and
originally the company the company dealt
most with the App Store optimization so
we would have different clients that we
would help with optimizing their their
pages and their stores on the App Stores
but the company was acquired uh
approximately uh over a year ago by
Zinga the the mobile gaming company um
and basically the the to try and sum up
what we do is um we create technologies
that are intended to help Zinga with
monitoring uh audience reaction to games
measuring how uh the games perform with
users and also there's a lot to do with
uh with creative efforts with trying to
optimize the creatives that Zinga
creates for the games for the way the
games are marketed and for the ads that
that the games have so the what's
interesting is that even though the
company was was acquired we still remain
very much the the the company that we
were within Zinga so the nature of our
work has changed and obviously we got
somewhat bigger
but the the DNA that the company had I
think really sustained itself through
the acquisition and in it something that
I think is also uh very evident in the
efforts that we have uh these days in
this kind of the way we all grouped
together and and um this Instinct we all
had of of reaching out to each other and
see how we can help phenomenal wonderful
tell me a little bit about um about
where you were on October 7th in the
morning where did this whole thing catch
you so when when it started uh I was
sleeping early in the morning there was
I I woke up from the sound of the the
intercepts uh of the Rockets over Tel
Aviv and I remember waking up and
thinking okay that sounds like a rocket
interceptions but but just I had this
thought that said well you know it it
happens sometimes maybe it's not an out
of the ordinary event and I was woken up
by uh phone call from my mom who said uh
you should really uh you know open the
television and and see what's happening
in the news and um still there was uh I
think maybe some denial like in in the
first couple of minutes I still thought
well maybe it's just you know some guys
got through the fence or whatever I
don't know if if maybe it's not as bad
as it looks but but it became uh clear
very very early on that uh that we're
looking at something very different and
then you know we all have our friends on
WhatsApp who who some you know uh I used
to work in in media uh before I worked
for M you were a you are a correspondent
for right I was a correspondent for
channel 13 so you know you us you have
the friends you have the WhatsApp groups
and and it was very clear early on what
was happening and
wow what happened then so you know fast
forward Maven is taking part in a
variety of efforts from funds to H on
activity um taking an active role but
should let's let's talk a little bit
about how the events transpired from
that moment that we realized that
something was going on what what really
went down there what was the prog so
early on it started uh right in the
first de to it started as more of kind
of um independent just a a a need and a
will by people to do something it wasn't
really an organized effort yet and you
know we we get on on Zoom we talk to
each other and each person tries to sort
of figure out okay what is the area that
I think I could probably fit in with
already very early on there was talk
about uh the old issue of of public
diplomacy and the way things are seen in
the media so I started to think well
okay maybe I can somehow fit into that
and people who come from a more Tech
side start to think of okay how can we
help I think um it it took a couple of
days for things to get really um to to
become more organized and the way we
work now is um there are a couple of
initiatives like flag initiatives that
are supported by us the the main thing
is there is a fund that was started by
by Zinga uh with a $300,000 fund that is
sifted through this by Zinga the global
company yeah this is by Zinga but sifted
through us to different of course of
course yeah um the majority of that fund
is dedicated to helping uh families who
who B orphans now as a result of of the
attack there uh yeah different families
one of them families with with babies
and there is a large sum of that fund
that goes into helping them food shelter
uh some of them need a transportation
because they've been displaced and how
how and why did you choose that as the
main source of contribution there many
toys to help you you chose this specific
one tell me a little bit more I think
there there was a sense and I think that
sense still exists today that um first
of all you know if we put aside
everything that's going to happen now
and any kind of existence that we can
still do there is there was a basic
sense that we all had of just the
immense tragedy that the people who live
uh in in uh what is it referred to ASA
have been going through and I think it
was very clear early on that um you know
without even talking about what's gonna
happen and what uh sort of uh how things
are gonna evolve we we understood that
there are people whose lives have been
impacted not for the next month or two
but basically for for the rest of their
lives and I think it's it was and still
is very important for us to make a
difference in things that are not just
the needs that are happening now which
is also important and we have
initiatives along that line but mostly
to see how can we help people years
forward and uh so so that a big effort
but it's not the only thing uh that that
the funds go to there are also things um
that there really are more in the the
basic day-to-day needs of of other
people so for example uh there was a big
need in some communities for suitcases
to because people were displaced and
they had to move around things that they
had in their homes and they had to move
sometimes from the north to from the
south to the north so we help them with
that uh there are initiatives a lot of
them are not just uh funded by that fund
but also our people uh take an active
role in that packaging food sending
supplies uh for example uh volunteering
for organizations like latet which had
to do with food packaging and how is
that what what is how does this impact
the day today so you know how how does
Maven look like you know the day before
the war started and the day after from
an organization's perspective you know
internal communication energy levels
Employee Engagement you know what what's
happening there so I think uh uh the
interesting is there are basically two
efforts one effort is the effort that we
all take part in which is the actual
assistance and thinking what are the
initiatives we can take part in and
where can we Don it and the other effort
that is done by the company uh by by
mavens as a company also by Zinga but
but what we feel more directly is by
mavens which is ensuring that
everybody's okay everybody's not just
physically safe but everybody's also
coping mentally it's very important for
everybody to make sure that um yes we
you know we all want to contribute we
all want to do stuff but it's also very
very natural for a person to feel that
he's not up for it at the moment and uh
there are also people who have been very
directly impacted by the events of
October 7th so making sure that
everybody has the space to uh contribute
but but there is no pressure and you do
things in your own pace and uh we get
calls from our managers on a daily basis
to to make sure that we're fine that
we're safe that we don't need anything
this is also something that is very much
felt from Zinga as a company as as a
corporation the safety of their
employees in Israel making sure they
have mental uh uh Health if needed
making sure that um that people are
communicated too with their managers and
with regards to the actual initiatives I
think you could see very early on that
the the company just made a giant shift
there are a lot of people in
mavens who that that is this is now
their uh I don't know exactly how long
it will be that way but this is now the
main focus of their of their work and
teams that were set up very early on I
mean I have old days that uh this is
what I deal with and then people who do
it much much more than me and things
happen very quickly you can really feel
it that uh things are set up in a way
that is um you know we look at it as as
a project and and the deadlines are
sometimes you know they have
repercussions for for lives in this case
as opposed to to our everyday uh
job there is this particular one that
caught my attention of with trauma
therapists um and I believe it was a it
was it was it's run by Shalon senior
product producer and Maven tell me a
little bit about
this this is really an amazing
initiative that that Shalon took upon
herself uh um of taking I don't remember
the exact number of of therapists but
taking therapists who basically do it on
a volunteering basis and connecting
those therapists to people who now need
uh you know mostly people who have been
impacted directly by the events and you
now need mental health obviously we as
employees in the company were not a
therapist but what we can contribute to
that and what we do is basically the we
refer to it as marketing but it's not
really marketing it's more making sure
that um we find the right therapists
wherever they may come from and that we
connect them to the right people and
that people know that this exists it it
connects a little bit to another project
that we have um which is more of a tech
project but it's it's kind of similar
which is something called Ezra which is
basically a system that uh was developed
by by people in our R&D Department which
uh is there dedicated to connecting
people who can and are willing to help
with people who may need that help not
just on a mental health basis it's
basically somewhat of a chatbot where
you can go in and say hey I'm I'm
looking for a person who can help me um
get groceries to people who need help
I'm a mental health uh person who wants
to help whoever we can and that chatbot
connects you to uh to other people and
there are already dozens of people who
were connected through it that that's
incredible um what has been your
personal
experience working through this and and
experiencing this H this vibrancy of
creation of of people coming together
what has it been like being at the
center of all
this um it's been a it's a weird
experience I think for for everybody
because um you know first of all just on
a personal basis I still uh I find
myself almost every day uh uh in
disbelief that uh that that it happened
and that this is what we're now living
through I think however that
um
that you know uh inserting ourselves
into situations where we can be
effective and we can be helpful in
creating issues it helped us um not just
feel that we're doing something good I
think it also helps us cope with it um
it's obviously difficult to work on the
regular everyday projects we have uh
these days and I think that if we were
not doing something to help a lot of us
would just be kind of sitting and these
are not good days to be sitting around
in front of the television no they're
not with everything that we were seeing
so it's been very helpful um it also uh
forces us quote unquote to do something
which we might not have done otherwise
which is uh to interact with as many
people in the company that we can I'll
just give you a brief example of maybe
you signed the materials we have a
project called uh Dan louder which is
yes yes that's the bracelets yeah that
that we created and designed and and we
now give in honor of those who who lost
their lives at the the Nova Festival so
regardless of the fact that I think it's
it's an important thing to do it also
you know it makes it we get out of the
house we meet each other people who I
would usually meet in an office I now
meet them in a very different
surrounding um it it helps keep you
connected to to the place you work
for yeah yeah I I I completely I
completely see that and and I think on a
larger on a larger note you know what
I've been experiencing and observing
over the last um you know couple of
weeks as we've as we've been doing this
is is really the this what what you're
mentioning both the the the the first of
all there's turbo evins that happen and
every person has their own personal
relationship to to what happened and and
a deep sense and wanting to contribute
then there's a deep sense of of wanting
to be meaningful and to do something and
not sit at home and and and and be a
bystander and um and at the same time
and what's been really remarkable is
that then organizations like like Maven
and Zinga and others have really come
together to support people support
employees create a and facilitate an
environment that that catalyzes these
create this creation not one project not
for two but but it sounds like what what
you've described was that Zinga and
Maven actually um helped facilitate an
environment as a platform for
initiatives and um which which is really
remarkable and and whether it's directly
done by by zingo or Maven or whether
it's the fact that employees came and
just did it but they were able to do it
and we all know that you know not every
place to work you know allows you to
just go and and and fulfill on this on
this drive I think that's really really
great and I think that's that's a that's
AIG big takeaway that I'm that I'm
coming out of this this conversation
with and um you know as an entrepreneur
and as a as a CEO I I I aim to to be a
platform Creator like what you're
describing here where in these times the
people that work with me and around me
have the capacity and the tenacity to go
and create so alone thank you very much
for I really apprciate thank you very
much my
pleasure
[Music]